Mind your decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
Cards numbered one through six are placed facedown on a table.
The cards are then shuffled.
You and I each select a card at random.
You take a look and see your card is a two.
I take a look and see the number on my card.
I then ask, "Would you like to trade cards?" The higher card wins the game.
How should you answer?
This game is from a TED-Ed talk by the chess grandmaster Maurice Ashley
I thank Joe for suggesting this problem.
Pause the video if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
Most people think about the game as follows: Suppose your card is a 2.
There are 4 cards that are higher than 2 and just one card that's lower than 2
It seems like there's a 4 out of 5 or 80% chance that the other card is higher,
and that it would be a good idea to trade the 2.
But in this game, it's not a random choice.
I first saw my card and then asked if you'd like to trade; how does that change the game?
We need to analyze using game theory - the science of strategy.
First a definition:
A strategy is "strictly dominated" if another strategy has a higher payoff regardless of what others do.
You should never play a strictly dominated strategy!
Suppose that my card is a 6.
Would I ever trade a 6?
No!
Since 6 is the highest card it always wins and I would always keep this card.
Trading 6 is a strictly dominated strategy.
So we want to eliminate the option of trading a 6, but where do we go from there?
We can actually repeat this process. It's known as the iterated elimination of strictly dominated strategies or IESDS.
Here's the algorithm:
We first look for dominated strategies in the game.
We ask, "Are there any?" If there are we eliminate those dominated strategies.
We then consider the reduced game and again look for dominated strategies.
We then ask are there any in the reduced game? If so, we eliminate them and then we repeat the process.
We continue doing this until we cannot find any more dominated strategies. At this point, the answer is no.
Then any remaining strategy is reasonable. Let's apply IESDS to this game.
We start out with the card of a 6.
We know that trading 6 is a strictly dominated strategy. So we eliminate that option.
In the reduced game 5 is the highest card.
Would we ever want to trade a 5?
We would only want to trade a five if we knew the other person was offering a six.
But we know that neither player is going to be offering a six.
Therefore trading five is a strictly dominated strategy in this reduced game
So we want to eliminate this option.
From here we can continue this process in the reduced game trading 4 is a strictly dominated strategy. So we eliminate that.
We then eliminate trading three in this reduced game and then we can eliminate trading two.
We're left with just one card, which is a one.
Obviously trading one is a good idea because every other card is a higher number.
The conclusion, is that a rational person that wants to trade cards
must be looking at a card of a 1.
So let's go back to the situation.
Your card was a 2, I had taken a look at my card, and I asked, "Would you like to trade cards?"
Using the perfect logical reasoning of IESDS, you can conclude my card must be a 1 therefore
You must answer no, because you don't want to trade your two for a 1; you want to win the game with a two.
There's a lesson in this game that you should always consider the information and intention of others.
If an offer sounds too good to be true, it probably is!
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support.